a quick turnaround for a prime minister
who's barely got her feet under the
table back home just two weeks in and
now on the world stage thank you
greeting counterparts in New York
but for all the handshakes over sea it's
hardships at home dominating the agenda
for Liz truss what I want to say is a
growing economy a price guarantee for
household energy bills taken effect next
month the government's stepping in but
funding it by borrowing rather than
taxing the profits of big business a big
ideological shift the Prime Minister
steadfast didn't stick into it a Labor's
policy to tax the energy companies are
supported by 68 of the public according
to polls you're prepared to be unpopular
aren't you yes yes I am
what is important to be is that we grow
the British economy that is what will
ultimately deliver more money into
people's pockets and in order to get
that economic growth Britain has to be
competitive and if we put up taxes if we
have arbitrary taxes on energy companies
if we have high corporation tax we're
not going to get that investment and
growth which will ultimately damage
damage opportunities in this country and
that's what I'm bothered about the
self-declared change candidate of the
conservative leadership race parting
with a tax and spend consensus we've
long been living with you're planning to
reverse the corporation tax cut rise
you're scrapping National Insurance
increases a big boost to Big Business
and a tax cut that disproportionately
benefits rich people in this country is
that fair I don't accept this argument
that
cutting taxes is somehow unfair I mean
what what we know is people on higher
incomes generally pay more tax so when
you reduce taxes there is often a
disproportionate benefit because those
people pay more taxes in the first place
what I don't accept is the idea that tax
cuts on business don't help people in
general political arguments of the past
now returning growth high priority but
it comes with obvious political gamble
at the most uncertain of times what's
your message to people out there that
will be watching this how are
desperately worried about Rising
mortgage bills and interest rate Rises
it's going to be a rough winter isn't it
we are in very difficult Economic Times
we're facing Putin's war in Ukraine
which has pushed up the prices of energy
I'm determined that my government takes
every step and strains everything you to
help people to get the economy going to
make sure that we have a successful
economy and country that can weather
this very very difficult storm that
we're facing rough winter we get through
it we will get through it but economic
storm faced by Nations far beyond the UK
and how to tackle it the question for
governments for Liz truss its tax cuts
for business with wealth working its way
down to the pockets of the poorer in
time her U.S counterpart Joe Biden with
a very different approach tweeting to
say I'm sick and tired of trickle-down
Economics it has never worked we're
building an economy from the bottom up a
middle out
Liz Travis a prime minister comfortable
withdrawing political dividing lines and
clear-eyed in her approach she wants to
protect business and cut taxes to grow
the economy whatever the short-term
political cost she's gambling that pay
now will pay off ahead of a general
election in 2024 but that is a huge bet
this an economic crisis that looks set
to get worse the Prime Minister
confident she can weather the storm but
much of it depends on what voters think
so Bethy delayed Spotlight on Liz trust
then today so what did you learn from
speaking to her
well there was some tour wasn't there
Anna during the leadership race that
because she was Boris Johnson's
preferred candidate although he never
explicitly said that that she might be
continuity Boris Johnson well I can tell
you on the economy she is anything but
and this is a real break politically
which what with what we've had for the
past decade at all uh past decade or so
in terms of Taxation she wants low tax
she wants to protect business you know
expect a raft of policies around that
and deregulation and when I pointed out
to her that these policies might be
unpopular with the wider public I said
are you prepared about that she was very
clear she said yes I am I'm going for
growth and that is the priority but of
course it's a controversial approach and
I think there's sort of three groups
really that we should look to to see how
these policies land in the coming weeks
there's vastly the markets how will they
react there's been a weakening of
confidence in British assets with bonds
equity and Sterling all fall in uh over
recent weeks have been nervousness
around our policies later this week the
bank of England might feel like they
need to put up interest rates it could
be to the highest level in three decades
amid nervousness around inflation and
some of the falling values of British
assets so how can she assuage those
fears with the public how will they feel
about tax cuts for big business and also
richer earners wealthier people when
they are struggling so much in terms of
the cost of living will her energy price
guarantee which will give a typical
household a cap of about two and a half
thousand pounds on a bill will that be
enough to assuage their concerns or will
they look at the policies and think hang
on a minute the taxpayer is going going
to have to pay for this and we don't
like it and then what about her MPS can
she bring them behind her on Friday we
will get the mini budget that is when
the ideas really meet the reality we'll
look for some reaction and they come in
weeks we'll just get a sense of how
unpopular potentially is Liz trust
really prepared to be